the canceled culture claims another
scalp the media are mostly to blame but
we delve deeper to a much more
disturbing truth the media give us
exactly what we want then the left
ratchets up the rhetoric on climate
change we examine why the new
environmental militarism is doomed to
fail and finally Andrew yang learns that
his vote-buying scheme might not be
totally legal who would have thought
that all that more I'm Michael Knowles
and this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
they got another one that canceled
culture got another one this is a guy
Shane Gillis I think his name is
pronounced who you've probably never
even heard of Shane
Gillis was just brought onto Saturday
Night Live gets this big new gig and
he's gone and they take it away and it's
all over we knew this would happen
this was the inevitable consequence of
two or three days ago when Shane Gillis
first came into the cancel culture
crosshairs now it has happened
he gets brought in to Saturday Night
Live then he loses Saturday Night Live
and this is how he responds he tweets
out I'm a comedian who is funny enough
to get SNL that can't be taken away of
course I wanted an opportunity to prove
myself at SNL but I understand it would
be too much of a distraction I respect
the decision they made I'm honestly
grateful for the opportunity I was
always a MADtv guy anyway just funny
that's an obvious ly very gracious a
witty way to end that he has this little
joke about how he prefers the rival
comedy sketch show MADtv really it's the
only decent option he had he can either
make a big deal about it and complain
and whine but that wouldn't be a good
look and nobody knows who he is anyway
so it wouldn't reflect well on him
anybody who still likes SNL you know all
ten people in the audience or gonna
prefer SNL to this random guy so he made
the correct choice he made the best
option that was in front of him but this
is wrong this is outrageous and this is
wrong
show business is very hard all of it
acting writing directing all of it all
of it is very difficult to get work of
any kind in show business comedy is
probably the hardest of all it's the
hardest of all to make it in it's not
hard to get these little gigs but you
get a few gigs in comedy you get paid
peanuts and pretty much you're
guaranteed to die in obscurity
unless something magical happens which
is you could get picked up maybe for a
role on a sitcom maybe you get a role in
a movie or something but those are
really hard or you get the pinnacle of
the comedy jobs which is Saturday Night
Live and then maybe from there like
Jimmy Fallon you go from Saturday Night
Live to having your own late-night talk
show or something
there's there one or two of those jobs
Saturday Night Live is it that's the gig
this guy made it against all odds he
makes it to the top of the comedy pack
and then the swarm came in and took away
every single thing from him because of
jokes he made a year or more ago that
were just jokes and he's a comedian
telling jokes and now it's all gone this
is exactly what Dave Chappelle predicted
in his own Netflix comedy special a few
weeks ago he said this canceled culture
comes out and they they say hey you if
you've ever done anything wrong anything
that it's not even wrong just something
I object to we're gonna take away every
single thing you have here's Dave
Chappelle the next one's a little harder
I want to see if you can guess who it is
I'm doing an impression of alright I'm
getting the character yeah guess who it
is though okay here goes oh hey there if
you do anything wrong in your life dull
and I find out about it I'm gonna try to
take everything away from you and I
don't care what I find out could be
today tomorrow 15-20 years from now if I
find out you're finished who's that
that's you that's where the audience
sounds like to me
[Applause]
that's why I don't be coming out doing
comedy old fam cuz young is the worst
mother because I've never tried to
entertain in my life that clip it's made
the rounds people have loved it
conservatives obviously you hate
canceled culture but a lot of liberals a
lot of just comedians a lot of regular
people love that clip but that clip is
so much wiser so much wiser even than
people give it credit for what is
interesting about this whole saga with
Shane Gillis a guy that I don't know
anything about don't really care about
don't care about SNL never watch it
what's interesting is not that it
happened this is happening all the time
what's interesting is how it happened
because the strangest aspect of canceled
culture is it just seems to happen it it
doesn't seem like it's one person or one
group or just this person is controlling
all of it it's this swarm that comes in
and it feels as though we are powerless
to stop it but that is not exactly the
case and there's a lot of insight in
Chappelle's diagnosis we'll get to that
in a second we'll get to who's really
behind cancel culture but first if you
have bought a timeshare you probably
know the pitch right it's a great
investment it's a legacy for your kids
you can stay whenever you want wherever
you want you'll get vacation all the
time guess what none of that is true
none of it it's a scam it's a total scam
the ugly truth is that with the
timeshare you can never tell how much
it's really gonna cost or when it's
going to end and a lot of owners who are
trying to sell their time shares online
find out the hard way that it's not an
investment not only is it not a good
investment it's not an investment
because they can't get a single dollar
for it and you on top of that when you
factor in the rising annual maintenance
costs and assessment fees and whatever
other fees you're gonna get buying a
timeshare is like giving the timeshare
company a blank check for life even when
you die even when you are dead and gone
your family will get stuck with that
burden so stop the insanity today there
is a way out I have a members have been
stuck in timeshares it can be brutal
right now go to I cancel timeshare
dot-com tell them that I sent you
the Wesley Financial Group guarantees
they will league
get you out of your timeshare out of the
contract permanently or you pay nothing
to get your free information kit telling
you all about how it works go to I
cancel timeshare com that is I cancel
timeshare dot-com go there now you don't
want to pay a dollar more to those scam
artists than is necessary I cancel
timeshare comm will help get you a tour
you pay nothing so what's interesting
about this cancel culture is the
question of who is behind it it's the
swarm it's the Twitter mob it's the
crazy angry mob so the what happens is
the swarm comes and then the object of
the swarms ire loses their job how does
it happen who is to blame
specifically journalists quote-unquote
journalists they are I'm not going to
say it's just everybody and everyone is
all to blame no it is very practically
the journalists so-called and the
mainstream media who are driving this
because journalists from your one
independent reporter on Twitter all the
way up to the New York Times they are
not reporting newsworthy stories they
are simply dredging up character
assassination and all you have to do is
look at yesterday's news cycle the New
York Times ran front page big cover
story completely unsubstantiated
allegations they hid evidence that was
exculpate ori they hid the fact that the
people alleging crimes against Brett
Kavanaugh the Supreme Court justice
weren't actually alleging anything it
was people alleging crimes about people
who were alleging things who didn't
actually allege them it was bogus
character assassination that's the New
York Times the gray lady all the news
that's fit to print same thing as true
of the Washington Post same thing is
true throughout the mainstream media all
the way down to so-called independent
journalists or or independent outlets so
it is those guys they are doing worse
right now it wasn't always this way
it's been better before just remember
when FDR was president the journalists
didn't report on the fact that FDR was
bound to a wheelchair the President of
the United States cameras on him all the
time
a lot of people didn't know he was in a
wheelchair the journalists didn't report
on FDR's mistresses they didn't report
on JFK's mistresses they didn't report
on LBJ's mistresses now those guys all
have two things
in common one they are simply known by
three letters of an acronym and two
they're all Democrats so maybe that has
something to do with it but regardless
it was a time when journalists exhibited
discretion the you know frankly all
those mistresses were certainly more
newsworthy than this canceled culture
some guy sent three tweets ten years ago
and now you got to ruin his life this is
being driven by the journalists they
deserve our scorn when Trump goes out
and says they're the enemy of the people
he's half right
he's also half wrong why is that because
what are the journalists responding to
they're responding to you and me we'll
get to that in a second first how did
this happen
the way that this canceled culture thing
occurred with Shane Gillis is first an
independent journalist which means a guy
with a Twitter account named Seth Simons
came out dredged up a bunch of old clips
of the comedian telling jokes and then
framed it in a way that this was
supposed to be some horrible offence and
then Saturday Night Live and NBC ran
scared and fired the guy they just hired
that the New York Times picked up this
story those scum-sucking bottom-feeder
zatt the New York Times they blew the
whole story up and the guy loses his job
what did they find here's what they
found
here's what they found apparently a year
or two ago the comedian Shane Gillis the
comedian I'll note made some jokes here
is one joke about going to Chinatown
this is dishonest food there's nothing
there's nothing to it it's be meat a
chemical they made up to your body up
and noodles neuters the news of cheapest
thing in the world
we got chemical worst meat you can find
we got in there and we sat down and baby
girl was like I'm so excited for neuters
and I was like yo chill chill chill but
we had in the translation between you
and the waiter yeah it's just such a
hassle it's like can you I'm pointing it
this is the less I put number of like 57
did joke is that Chinese people have
different accents from english-speaking
people that's the joke it's and it's
true it's like the most obvious joke in
the world I'm not saying it's a good
joke I'm sure it's an obvious joke it's
a
a harmless joke the joke is that
stereotypically East Asians mix up the L
and the R sounds in English so he says
neuters instead of noodles but that's
true that is true those two letters do
get confused absolutely harmless joke
less offensive than making a joke about
Irish people drinking I mean so obvious
it's a joke about language he should
lose his job for that as he says yeah I
go to Chinatown and sometimes the people
speak with funny accents they do that
yeah that's right of course that's what
happens here's Seth Simon's next example
of Shane Gillis's terrible awful racism
from the same podcast from the same
conversation about Chinese restaurants
it's all it's it's funny too because
that's more annoying than any other
minority playing music at a restaurant
moving out on their phone do you think
Asian guys are trying to learn English
bothers me more than someone listening
like little Aussie bird welcome Chinese
that's hilarious yeah nice racism racist
racist it's basically the stereotype of
white people that we walk around all day
and are like yeah that's what happens
that's funny too that way you were over
there they'd be the white people being
like shut up
now what's incredible what's incredible
about this clip and actually I guess the
last clip too is not only are the jokes
not an example of racism whatever that
means anymore cuz racism has been
defined down to nothing by the left
they're actually jokes about racism the
the object of the joke is the racism in
the first clip he says neuters and he
uses this sort of stereotypical and
ostensibly offensive pronounciation and
then he says that was a good racism he's
admitting he's saying that was racist
what I said I shouldn't say that that's
bad to say that and then in the second
clip I mean even he says to his
girlfriend because she said the word
neuters and he said oh stop it stop it
chill be cool because he knows you're
not supposed to say that and the joke is
that incongruity how you're supposed to
behave and how you're actually behaving
and they talked about it in the second
clip they say yeah this is sort of what
what ethnic minorities must imagine
white people are doing all the time
complaining about minorities
but I guess if we were in China and we
were speaking the way that we speak they
would probably say the same things about
us so that is a joke about race
specifically a joke about racism he's
got to lose his job for that of course
he does because Seth Simon's this random
Twitter account wants to ruin someone's
life he wakes up in the morning he says
but I'm gonna ruin someone's life today
I don't I don't know what's going on in
my life but I've got such an empty pit
in my own life in my own soul that I'm
going to fill that today by destroying
somebody's life and so he pulls together
pulls the whole narrative together that
this comedian Shane Gillis I guess hates
Chinese people or something by finding a
different Chinese joke from a different
podcast that he told the podcast has a
bunch of guys on it and Shane has the
audacity to joke that the Chinese have a
lot of abortions here's the joke
shoutout to NYC grappling krug blue NYC
grappling club grappling club NYC calm
you're speaking like him now
thank you grab rank Rob taught me many
valuable lessons not just about fighting
put the mental game that's why I catch
up you me nation or handy kisses
training I have not seen a Asian
Handicap person agent Asian yet so put
him down okay that was the juniors you
catch the joke at the end so there
they're all telling the same joke about
the ELLs in the arse which every
comedian and virtually everyone else has
told at some point and then someone says
I can't tell if you're handicapped or
Chinese their joke being I can't tell if
you are speaking English poorly because
it's not your first language or if
you're speaking English poorly because
you have mental deficiency is it really
funny to explain jokes and then it they
say well I've never seen a handicapped
Chinese person they put them down
earlier than that this is a dark joke
very dark humor specifically it's a joke
about abortion it is a joke playing on a
fact that is obviously true which is
that China very famously had a policy of
compulsory abortion for over 35 years
and that policy was called the one-child
policy
the joke is they kill their babies as a
government policy which is true
doesn't make it nice doesn't make
nice fact about life but it is true and
what comedy does is it subverts all
these sorts of awful things like
coercive government or like mandatory
abortion or like cultural mores that's
what it is doing now the crowning
achievement of this guy's career this
comedian Shane Gillis ruined it's gone
you can't have it because of some jerk
named Seth Simons and Seth Simon's is
indeed a very bad man who did a very bad
thing who should apologize and seek
forgiveness but it is not just his fault
and it's not just the journalists fault
there is another group of people very
much at fault here who should seriously
take a look inside of themselves we'll
get to that group in one second but
first I've got to thank our friends over
at zip recruiter because when we hire
people we don't fire them right away and
the reason is we get great candidates
from zip recruiter cafe alter is co o
Dillon miss quits needed to hire a
director of coffee for his organic
coffee company but he was having trouble
finding qualified applicants so what did
he do he switched to zip recruiter zip
recruiter doesn't depend on candidates
finding you it finds them for you so the
technology identifies the people with
the right experience and then invites
those people to apply for your job it's
not like you just thrown spaghetti at
the wall it's gonna go out find the
people and you get qualified candidates
fast Dillon posted his job on zip
recruiter he said he was impressed by
how quickly he had great candidates
apply he also used zip recruiters
candidate rating feature to filter his
applicants so he could focus on the most
relevant ones you know you don't want
just anybody coming you've got very
specific criteria for the jobs that you
want with results like that it is no
shock that four out of five employers
who post on zip recruiter get a quality
candidate within the first day time is
money time is money for your company it
can be really hard to staff up when
you're talking to guys who work for a
conservative media company in Los
Angeles they're like can seven
conservatives out there very hard to
find the right people who want to work
at your job who would be the right fit
head on over to zip recruiter zip
recruiter is effective for businesses of
all sizes tricep recruiter for free at
the web address zip recruiter comm slash
Knowles kena WL II
ass zip recruiter comm slash Knowles
kayo wles don't waste any more time go
to the best right now get your top
candidates get the top employees zip
recruiter comm slash Knowles Canada wles
zip recruiter the smartest way to hire
so this guy Seth Simon's this critic who
got Shane Gillis's job taken away is a
jerk he's a huge jerk the journalists
who do this generally are huge jerks not
just their fault HL Mencken said
democracy is the theory that the people
know what they want and that they
deserve to get it good and hard and
that's it look journalism is
increasingly driven by cliques so also
subscriptions you know we we have
subscribers but largely mostly clicks
and so journalists again increasingly in
many ways give the audience what they
want it's not like you just have the
regular subscribers and you you've got
them and you've got their trust and you
keep it going around and like in the old
days I mean you were going down to
individual clicks at this point that's
how you make money through online ad
sales and so the journalists give the
audiences what they want in the
immediate moment how they can monetize
every last penny out of their content
and audiences want this trash they do
they want it they want the thrill of
cheap drama increasingly they want a
replacement for the virtue lacking in
their own lives they want something to
fill the god shaped holes in their heart
and in our sick culture that takes the
shape of vindictiveness and politics you
just want the drama you know the silver
lining here for Shane Gillis is that
absolutely nobody has watched Saturday
Night Live since Bill Murray left or at
least since noir McDonald left and so
I'm not not sorry for for Shane Gillis
in particular you know he'll probably go
on and have a fine career I am sorry
though for us I'm sorry for us I'm sorry
we live in this culture we we are living
in a colder less funny less humane
society today because of canceled
culture and look it's so easy to condemn
cancel culture it's so easy to say it's
ugly it's so ugly we all know it's ugly
but why do we have canceled culture we
have it we have that culture because we
in a colder less funny less humane
society grace is the only thing that
prevents life from being miserable life
can be miserable it can't I don't think
it's miserable I have a great time I am
as joyful as I've ever been really have
a good because of grace not because I
think I deserve something and I'm so
proud and I'm gonna go get that guy and
I'm gonna ruin his life and I'm gonna
take that guy's career away and then I'm
gonna go home at night and feel really
good about myself no grace grace is the
only thing that prevents life from being
so miserable the quality of Mercy it's
wonderful we pray for it and we give it
out to others it's what the Lord's
Prayer is forgive us our sins as we
forgive those who trespass against us
forgive us our debts forgive us our
trespasses please please forgive us and
we will forgive others in the same way
and we are losing the sense of grace
more and more each day we're celebrating
pride we're celebrating entitlement
we're growing the entitlement state
returning of to a culture of Pride and
entitlement away from one of grace and
humility this this actually has a big
lesson for conservatives there is a
lesson beyond the unfortunate aspect of
canceled culture beyond the graceless
society the lesson for conservatives is
this shame gillis lost out because he
was playing the mainstream game he was
trying to win the approval of the
mainstream culture go on the mainstream
comedy show keep everything mainstream
with the mainstream advertisers in the
mainstream television network if you
seek the approval of the mainstream
popular culture you are suspended
so precariously like a spider held over
a burning fire to use the imagery of
sinners in the hands of an angry god if
you don't care about the approval of the
mainstream popular culture if you mock
that mainstream pop culture that bizarre
perverse pop culture if you hold it in
disdain then it can't hurt you and it
can't come get you they can't get me
they can get
Gillis because he's playing their game
they can't get me they can't get Drew
they can't get Benton if you just say no
I don't want it they can't get you you
know I I'm the reason I even mentioned
me and Drew and been in this and and
Matt Walsh is that those ghouls over at
the leftist media operative
organizations like Media Matters and a
couple of others they could have power
over us but only if we give it to them
they actually have no power over us why
because we just make fun of them they
only have power if they make you flinch
they only have power if they make you
blink they only have power if you grant
their ridiculous premises but if you
don't if Shane Gillis I mean he was in
trouble because he was already trying to
get his way into the mainstream
but if Saturday Night Live or some other
comedy program just turned to that awful
little independent journalist and said
yeah you know what I don't care what you
have to say get out of here I mean even
he made some joke about Andrew yang this
comedian Shane Gillis and Andrew yang
said that's fine we'll sit down and talk
but you know whatever you shouldn't lose
this job
that's grace that's forgiveness that's
that's nice what is this awful Twitter
person this cancel culture person what
right does he have to get Shane Gillis
to lose his job because this awful
Twitter person is offended on behalf of
other people on behalf of Andrew yang on
behalf of Chinese Americans no you can't
be offended on behalf of somebody just L
make fun of them say who cares the
lesson for the Conservatives here is
don't do it do not seek the approval of
the New York Times do not seek the
forgiveness of media matters I mean
media matters they're a bunch of
degenerates they're absolutely
disgusting people who hold disgusting
views and and live a disgusting life
where their whole life is just trying to
ruin the careers of others because they
don't have any arguments to answer the
arguments of their political opponents
they deserve pity in a certain sense I
don't care I'm not gonna try to destroy
their lives but they have no credibility
this this Twitter guy who spends all his
days trying to ruin people's career so
you don't owe him an answer you don't
owe him an answer on anything that's how
we
look at the left that's how we got to
look at that mainstream culture
they're never gonna like you they're not
they're simply going to try to destroy
you and you've got to get that through
your head and then only then can you
start building up a decent culture
yourself now the hysteria is not just on
canceled culture it's not just all the
way up they are turning up the dials and
amping up the rhetoric on everything all
the way up to and including climate
change they are amping up their rhetoric
they're using bellicose language they're
talking about climate change like it's
world war two not just IOC saying it but
other people as well we'll see why
because there's nothing new Under the
Sun and the left doesn't know anything
about history so they don't realize they
are just repeating the same old tired
tropes of past leftists we'll get to
that in a second we'll see why it's an
old idea we'll see why there's nothing
new Under the Sun in the Andrew yang
campaign he thinks he's got a novel idea
to pay voters it's the oldest idea Under
the Sun we told of that in a second but
first you got to go to daily wire comm
ten bucks a month hundred dollars for an
annual membership what do you get give
me you get the Enric laven show you get
the Ben Shapiro show you get the Matt
Walsh show you get to ask questions in
the mailbag coming up on Thursday you
get to ask questions backstage you get
another Kingdom you get everything and
you get most importantly the leftist
tears tumblr which is the only
environmental catastrophe that you
really have to fear go to daily wire.com
we'll be right back with a lot more
the left is totally amping up its
rhetoric on climate change that's the
old euphemism now they're calling it
something different and it's no accident
you know we went from in the 70s global
cooling to then in the 80s and 90s
global warming too then in the 2000s
climate change too then in the 2010s
climate crisis now they're calling it
climate catastrophe that's what they're
saying on presidential town halls on CNN
so a major environmental activist
Jonathan Safran Foer who is also a
novelist he was on MSNBC and he openly
invoked the imagery of World War two in
the battle against the Sun monster
climate change climate catastrophe to
describe how we need to mobilize and
unite to fight this awful foe here he is
acting on one's values can feel really
good you know can feel and spy with you
I agree with you I think we probably
shouldn't use the word sacrifice in this
context because if you don't act on your
values you don't feel good and the
consequence could be the wrecking of the
earth absolutely and there's a good
model for this in World War two the
homefront efforts that regular Americans
made regardless of their political
leanings or their socioeconomic
backgrounds driving at 35 miles per hour
we had a 94 percent income tax highest
rate income tax we had rations on foods
and in a really wonderful fireside chat
that I could never imagine our president
giving but FDR gave at the time he said
look not all of us have the privilege of
fighting on the other side of the ocean
against the enemy not all of us have the
privilege of producing munitions but we
can all participate on the homefront and
when we look back at the changes that we
have made during this period after we
have saved our free way of life
sacrifice is not the word we're going to
use and I think it's the same thing here
when we look back or when our kids a
contribution so this is it this is world
war 2 here we are and he's not the first
one to do this just a few months ago AOC
the future of the Democratic Party
according to Tom Perez the head of the
DNC compared climate change to world war
two as well here she is in a talk with
Tom easy coats I think that the part of
it that is
generational is that Millennials and
people have you know Gen Z and all these
folks that come after us are looking up
and we're like the world is going to end
in 12 years if we don't address climate
change and your biggest issue is your
your biggest issue is how are we gonna
pay for it and like this is the war this
is our World War two this is it this is
how well this is like our World War two
you know like it's just like what it is
they think this is a novel idea they
think this is a new strategy Joshua
Safran Foer Jonathan Safran Foer and AOC
they think there's a new idea this is
what we're gonna do we're gonna compare
our domestic policy agenda to a war and
that way we'll get all this unity it's
not a new idea it's an old idea it's a
very bad idea and it's certainly doomed
to fail
because it's never actually worked this
idea of comparing your domestic policy
agenda to a war goes all the way back to
an essay by the philosopher and
psychologist William James and the
essays called the moral equivalent of
war it's worth reading the essay
addresses how to sustain the political
unity and civic virtue characteristic of
war during times of peace so the idea is
you've heard this before why can't
America be as united as they were as we
all were after 9/11
why can't America go back to being so
United like we were during World War two
how do we get that back so the theory is
that you get that back by injecting
regular old domestic politics with a
heavy dose of militarism and this idea
has been embraced by a whole slew of
people but especially by modernists and
leftists for over a century so Mussolini
did this he did this very directly this
isn't some kind of crazy conspiracy
theory here he gave a speech called the
Battle of the grains speech in which he
explicitly invoked William James and
which he invoked this essay the moral
equivalent of war LBJ did this in our
own country in the war on poverty
Richard Nixon did this who by the way
Richard Nixon pretty left on his
domestic policy he did this with his war
on drugs he declared the war on drugs
Jimmy Carter did this he gave actually a
speech called
moral equivalent of war which was
directly based on the William James
essay and he did that on the energy
crisis we need to rally and unite and
get all of our civic virtue back to
address the energy crisis just like we
would in war and conservatives tend to
make fun of this kind of language
because it's hysterical and ridiculous
dear aoc compare recycling and using
those stupid paper straws instead of
plastic straws to compare that to
landing on the beaches in Normandy is a
little ridiculous it's not a world war
two this is us inventing problems
because we're too decadent and luxurious
so we make fun of it you know Ronald
Reagan joked he said we fought a war on
poverty and poverty one just row we
fought a war on poverty made things
worse we ended up spending a ton of
money didn't make anything better and in
many ways it harms the people that it
was intended to help what does it mean
about the language of war everybody uses
war as a matter of rhetoric I mean we
use war as a synonym for civil battle or
fights or debates obviously we talk
about the culture war that's very
different that's a figure of speech to
refer to some debate with the hyperbolic
and heightened language of war that is a
figure of speech the culture war when we
use that phrase describes political
divisions in the country with the left
does with their war rhetoric is actually
the opposite they're not trying to talk
about divisions in the country they want
to fabricate an actual equivalent to war
so that the whole country is a unified
behind certain radical domestic policies
that is not going to work in the long
run why not because there is no actual
equivalent of war shrinking your plastic
straws is not like landing on the
beaches of Normandy it's not the same we
know that the Sun Monster is not as big
a threat as al-qaeda terrorists who
knock down our buildings and kill 3,000
americans we know that the Sun Monster
and the temperature increasing possibly
possibly by one degree over a hundred
years isn't the same as the Nazis
invading isn't the same as the Japanese
bombing Pearl Harbor it's just not the
same we all know that and even if it
were though think about this they're
calling for the more liquid
they've been calling to use this world
war two militaristic language for a long
time now even if there were a way to do
it if you are the one who's really eager
for war and to create the sense of war
and the sacrifice of war and the feeling
of war if you are encouraging war you're
probably on the wrong side of that
equation aren't you probably on the
wrong side of that question maybe you've
got to rethink that if you're saying we
need to be we need to feel like we're in
a war all the time maybe what you're
selling isn't what we need as a society
I'm not eager for war I like peace peace
is really nice it's so ironic that the
left accuses the right of being war
mongers gives me like a big strong
military we want a big strong military
because the only way you can have peace
is to be prepared for war you have peace
through strength a strong military is a
good deterrent for war whereas a weak
military is welcoming a war it's
encouraging a war it's daring your
opponents and your enemies to come
attack you so they call us warmongers
because we want peace whereas they
pretend that they want peace and all
they ever do is clamor for war in the
feeling of war bad idea and they're
doing it around climate change because
this is the sort of central religious
issue for the left and the fall of the
Soviet Union after the advance of
secularism what took the place of of
communism and socialism in the left-wing
religious imagination what took the
place of traditional religion
Christianity is environmentalism
increasingly and so I think that the war
language is really weak for them but the
religious language is really good and we
just found out in New York City I'm
broadcasting from New York right now
they announced that 1.1 million public
school students are allowed to skip
class without penalty to join the global
youth climate strikes on Friday this is
being reported by a lot of people
including the New York Times 1.1 million
public school kids get the day off to go
to a climate change rally now people are
shocked by this I'm not shocked at all I
think this makes perfect sense the New
York City school kids get off for
Christmas they get off for Hanukkah they
get off for the Christian holidays and
the Jewish holidays of course they
should get off for the leftist top
days because a leftism is a much more
popular religion in New York City at
least among the elites and the people
making these decisions as Christianity
or Judaism or anything else it's a
religious holiday it's not a protest it
this climate change rally is not a
political protest the rally is being
organized by the government it's being
organized by the mayor's office and by
the public schools so who are they
protesting they're not protesting
anybody what what they are doing is
putting on a religious ritual where they
are cut they're taking off from school
and they're going out and they're doing
oblations and they're they're trying to
stave off the Sun monster and to appease
the weather gods and to signal their
virtue and a signal to everyone around
them that they are good and moral and
upright and religious people even in a
world that laughs at actual religion
makes perfect sense to me that is going
to be more successful for the left in
the long turn it's too bad because
everybody's got to serve somebody and so
I would I would rather the left do is
actually come back to real religion and
worship God but I don't know that that's
going to happen anytime soon absent a
miracle so instead what they're going to
do is get more and more pulled into the
religion of leftism the religion of
climate change totally unfalsifiable
it's sad too that they need to exploit
kids this way look I'm pretty
conservative I mean I was born basically
smoking a cigar and campaigning for like
Bob Dole in my first-grade classroom but
if you told me that I could get a day
off from school to go out there and wear
a hippy bandana and protest the Sun
monster
sign me up man you just met your biggest
environmental activist in the world I'll
even prove through paper straws that day
if it got me off of school and so I bet
a lot of kids are gonna take them up on
this opportunity that's pathetic though
I mean that is a sign of true demagogues
to have to exploit children this way the
left does it all the time doesn't make
it any less pathetic but it's it's an
old idea and it's going to be fairly
effective conservatives need to find a
way to fight back and you're not gonna
fight back on just little political
points Andrew Breitbart was right
politics is down from culture culture is
down from religion we need to speak in
as compelling a religious way as the
left is doing with their false religion
and their false religion of materialism
now speaking
of old ideas that people are pretending
or new again Andrew yang Andrew yang the
wackiest candidate Andrew yang came out
and offered people a thousand dollars if
they donate to his campaign they have a
chance of winning a thousand dollars a
month for a year to show them how great
is a universal basic income plan is
here's Andrew yang at the debate
promising the plan my campaign will now
give a freedom dividend of $1,000 a
month for an entire year to ten American
families someone watching this at home
right now if you believe that you can
solve your own problems better than any
politician go to yang 2020 calm and tell
us how one thousand dollars a month will
help you do just that
this is how we will get our country
working for us again the American people
what's amazing is after yang said this
Pete Buddha judge was on the stage and
he sort of laughed and he said it's
original that's an original plan it's
not an original plan
well yang is saying is hey if you
support me I'll give you money hey can
you can I buy your vote that's not a new
plan that's the oldest plan in politics
that has been a plan in politics since
the first caveman was running for mayor
of the cave city and it looks like it
may be illegal I was wondering when I
watched the debate I thought there's no
way this is legal
how were you allowed to take campaign
donations and then just give it a way to
bribe people to vote for you so now
because the yang Yang campaign has said
that they've checked with lawyers and
it's totally kosher and it's absolutely
fun there is now a former FEC lawyer who
is a top litigator with the nonprofit
campaign Legal Center his name is
aadhavan OD he's saying not looking so
good direct quote to CNN although it's
hard to say with 100% certainty until we
know the details of the payouts on its
face yang this proposal to use campaign
money to help pay the day-to-day
expenses of selected people appears to
violate the law yeah gee you don't say
he says the fact that the payments
happen to be consistent with Yang's
campaign platform is irrelevant an
anti-tax candidate couldn't use campaign
money to pay people's taxes and a pro
income candidate can't use campaign
money to give people cash of course not
and this is my big issue
with Andrew yang he seems like a
perfectly nice guy I guess his campaign
is the wrongest campaign in in the
entire Democratic field and there are
some wackos you got the furry you've got
Lyle witha you've got Joe Biden beaten
up old Corn Pops with the six foot long
metal chain you've got a lot of weirdos
you got Bernie Sanders singing shirtless
in the Soviet Union during its honeymoon
I mean you got some whacky people in
there and yet and reang who has mostly
ironically but somewhat earnestly
attracted the support of some
conservatives he is still the wrong
ggest candidate in the whole race
because what he's essentially doing is
bribing people he's he's corrupting the
system in a way that the founders of our
country really feared which is that he's
purchasing votes he's trying to bribe
the people with their own money he's
trying to to turn the government into a
slush fund for people and and not just
that it's not even just the money
because there's always corruption in
government he's he's undermining the
dignity of the person human dignity by
saying he's predicting that automation
is going to destroy all the jobs I don't
think there's really evidence for that
we're at the lowest unemployment record
low unemployment right now so that
doesn't even really ring true as a
prediction but let's say the prediction
were true let's say some great
advancement happens with artificial
intelligence and all of a sudden you've
got very high unemployment rates
Andrew yang says the answer is to
basically bribe people bribe them to go
away here's some money go play video
games or do drugs or kill yourself
whatever you got to do but just don't
bother me because we're gonna be over
here in Silicon Valley making a lot of
money that is not a serious answer the
charitable read of that is that he's
simply naive and uninterested in people
the more cynical read or perhaps the
more realistic read depending on how you
look at the guy is that he just wants to
live his own life to to help the elites
to help the go-getters to help the
people at the top and he doesn't want
the hoi polloi and the proletarians to
come out and overthrow this system it
mean it's everything wrong with modern
capitalism or neoliberalism everything
wrong about it is in this yang campaign
right down to the unbelievable
corrosive effects disrespectful effects
of purchasing people's about perverting
our Democratic Republic in getting back
to the perversions of our Democratic
Republic it's not just happening in the
pop culture with canceled culture it's
not just happening in our government
with the Democratic presidential
campaign it's happening in our academic
institutions too and this is probably
the biggest threat because the Academy
the campus is just a preview of what
your country is going to look like so
you look at the campuses that's what
your country is going to look like in 20
years it happened in the 60s you had all
this craziness on campus within 20 years
you had tenured radicals who were
totally subverting the country and
that's what's happening now so I bring
this up because I'm about to kick off my
yeah tour my young America's Foundation
speaking tour we just released the dates
it's starting up I think September 26
they use USC and then we're going to
Yale we're going to GW we're gonna stop
in Ohio and Kentucky and Georgia and
Florida would be all over the place you
can check those dates on my Twitter page
and on young America's Foundation
but last semester when I was giving a
speech at Cal State Los Angeles yeah
just discovered through leaked internal
emails that it wasn't the students who
were so crazed with my speech and trying
to get me cancelled at the Academy it
was the faculty members there was a
faculty member Carlos de nada this is
what he said he said that I triggered
him emotionally and physically how did I
trigger him physically couldn't possibly
tell you he writes a letter to the whole
faculty and staff
dear faculty and staff as a faculty
member who was emotionally and
physically triggered by last week's free
speech attack on our campus yada yada
yada he goes on and on he's not a very
good writer so he's very wordy he says
how can we communicate to you who have
been entrusted with the well-being of
our students that this poses a threat to
the mental well-being of many of our
students staff and faculty that it
violates their sense of safety on their
campus this is campus canceled culture
this is canceled culture brought to
institutions of higher learning which is
terrible if you cancel ideas in the
university then there is truly no reason
for the university to
exist and that's exactly what they want
to do I mean this guy said it was an
outright attack my speech I gave a
speech on how nations should have
immigration laws that was the whole
speech he said it was an outright attack
on the psyches and well-being of more
than a few students faculty and staff an
outright attack and that's why it's got
to be banned that's why it's got to be
canceled I nearly had to cancel class
because of a shake and I am about seeing
a build the wall banner on our campus if
you are so mentally weak like this
professor Carlos Tejada obviously is
that you cannot handle hearing an
opposing view much less the view that
nations should have immigration laws
which is the entire thesis of mine
strong if you can't handle that you
shouldn't be teaching you should be
cancelled you should have your job
canceled it's unbelievable because I'm
paying this guy's salary as an LA
resident they go on there were so many
more of these they refer to the young
America's Foundation as white
supremacists they they referred to me as
a racist and a racist person he said
it's a blatantly racist message for
saying that a nation should have
immigration laws I mean goes on and on I
don't know I mean obviously this guy's
not getting a lot of work done and the
other professors who are with him aren't
getting a whole lot of work done because
they're just spending all their time
trying to get conservatives banned from
campus yelling at the administration for
not banning us what it forces is the
uncomfortable conclusion that we can't
just let this go and see where the chips
fall we have to cancel cancel culture
which is an act of the will it is a very
specific act how do we do this G K
Chesterton wrote about it pretty well he
said there is a thought that stops
thought and that is the only thought
that ought to be stopped you have to
stop that you can't just wait and hope
it turns out for the best you have to
actively cancel cancel culture you've
got to cancel the cancel errs whether
they're on college campuses especially
if they're on college campuses or
whether they're in politics or whether
in there they're in the pop culture
writing about and hiring people for
television shows you've got to cancel
the cancel errs this problem won't fix
itself on its own we've got to do it
that's gonna take some moral clarity
some cultural clarity and some political
will
unfortunately we're lacking in a lot of
that these days but that is the only way
they're going to fix the culture that's
our show
come back tomorrow in the meantime I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael Nolt
show see you then
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boy
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director pavel white
house key edited by Danny D'Amico audio
is mixed by Mike or Amina hair and
makeup is by Jessa alvera and our
production assistant is Nick Sheehan the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
hey everybody's Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show cancel culture it
doesn't just destroy people's dreams
people's lives it's an offense against
everything that makes this country great
that's what it's supposed to be but the
left really wants to cancel is America
we'll talk about it on the Andrew Klavan
show an anthem played
[Music]